Chicago Illinois o doing four shows out
there this week do yourself a favor
couple of ticks left scoop them up grab
the squad and come see the boys yeah
baby then we're going to be in
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
T show there San Francisco San Jose
Washington DC then we're ending it
ending the Year big at the Filmore in
Philadelphia two shows limited tickets
there peace yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is R you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it after
they go to be classy or if they're just
a big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host Tes Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toties in the new edition she's
upstairs raking leaves oh good for her
drunk but she's still raking the leaves
getting the housework done all right
Mike Coos is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is an international businessman he's
my best pal in the whole wide world give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up
gang thanks for tuning in jacket as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
YouTube as you know those numbers are TR
cooking and then obviously the greatest
website of all time www.
p.com gang check it out it's a freaking
party over there and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours he crosses the
te's and he dots the eyes give it up for
T-Bone MC scruffing Toby McMullen
everybody what up boys we got such a
good vibe in the Edition she comes in
makes you feel like family nice and cozy
best we got a killer in the studio here
ain't lying gang the long hair ain't
lying cuz we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time she is a very
funny very successful standup comedian
actor podcaster author and producer and
you might have seen her in but not
limited to we got BET's Comic View we
have Gotham Comedy live we have laughs
this is not happening Last Comic
Standing the Church of What's Happening
Now WTF with Mark Maron Dish Nation The
Joe Rogan Experience the cabin Wendy
Williams Kelly Clarkson The Daily Show
the talk Jennifer Hudson Jimmy Kimmel
Seth Meyers big city greens zoee 102 the
degenerates she's on tour right now and
of course she's the star of the Miss Pat
show 33 episodes of that about to have a
fourth season baby look out she has her
own Netflix Netflix special want to hear
something crazy an amazing podcast to
pat down she's also the author of her
own autobiography rabbit and she has a
brand new show on bet that is absolutely
killing it Miss Pat settles it give it
up for Miss Pat everybody there we go
look at that girl's a worker
laundry list man you should you should
do this for a living you can sell some
people you make me want to know who the
hell is
Miss I was just waiting on you to give
out the air I almost ran out a coup I
was like shouldn't he be said all this
[__] ain't you too big to be running all
that off you need to start reading you
too thick for all that without Tak I was
concerned I was going to give you CPR
over there tell me get my inhaler will
you I was tired of listen to you and I'm
big too I say brother take a breath take
a breath brother I'm
sweating out three times I know
congratulations on the new show thank
you Miss Pat settles it yeah I'm a
judge how the hell did that happen I've
been to jail
enough I know my rights godamn it pass
the bar in Georgia let's go I didn't
need no bar I've been to the bar to
drink and eat but not that kind of
bar thank you so much for coming in uh
give us the the back story give us the
origin story of Miss Pat oh I'm just a
little old lady a little old girl from
the interner CATE of Atlanta got you
know I used to traffic cocaine got shot
a cple got hit by dump truck had two
baby by married man had a couple STDs
and I turned my life around now you're a
judge look at that I'm a [__] judge
the least craziest thing I think I heard
you got hit by a dump truck is that
right chasing a
man wait what chasing a
man you were chasing a guy across the
street and you got hit by a dump truck
no uh I was um I jumped off for a little
over paath on to his car one time cuz I
was in love with him okay and he drugged
me Jesus Christ oh I'm let me tell you
something when you get a good black man
that can't read and the sex is delicious
you'll do some crazy [__] everybody was
wondering what was wrong with Whitney
Houston I know what was wrong with
Whitney Houston she got that ghetto pipe
and it ain't got no turn off
man shout out to Bobby Brown huh putting
it down bring the heat yeah holy [__]
okay all right so uh who was in the
house when you were growing up mom dad
brothers sisters give Mom uh three
brothers and a sister okay your mom
three brothers and a sister all right
and was this an apartment or a house uh
efficiency we one time we just live
where it was a living room and a kitchen
and a bathroom and then apartment we
would pull as
[__] we got evicted all the time but we
never got sat outside on the street
because my mama knew she knew the system
so she be like pack your [__] they be
here in 29 days so we whatever we she
was yeah whatever we moved in we really
never unpacked we just lived out of the
pack [__] so we just put tape on it put
it in our car and get the [__] off I
respect the hustle baby damn one step
ahead all right okay and this was all in
inner city Atlanta all these of Atlanta
yeah okay and that's where you live now
you live in you live in Atlanta now I
live in Georgia I live where I grew up
at I know those days are long behind you
well I can't I can't afford they don't
[__] justify it when you bring a
Starbucks and white people walk in their
dogs ain't no black folks [__] going
down over there baby it's so much money
to live in the West in now really I
called one day they was like uh what
they said uh $5,500 I said but you ain't
got rid of all the crackhead yet not
paying $5,500 for no crack but you know
wasn't think about White America y'all
can see some [__] happen y'all walk with
your' head up in the air and don't pay
attention black F be like y'all don't
see that sh going down we see it we're
like a horse with blinders on I just got
to get to that Starbucks get my Machi AO
and call trying to get that property
value so they it's still $5,500 sometime
to live in the west end but all the rof
ra ain't gone and what so what did your
mom do when you were a kid was what was
she was she doing for her job uh
watching soap
poppers okay she literally watched The
Young and the Restless we lived off
government assistant okay and we just
mve from place to place
damn no please no were you in school at
all that time same School were you
moving around we moved do you know what
the good part about my mom we would get
evicted in the community so we never had
to change school that's great all right
we Chang address but we never changed
School your M it all figured out that's
great you still make the bus in the
morning let's go before they check they
did uh credit checks for you to move
into a place oh you got the money move
the [__] in um how were your grades
growing up were you a good student uh I
don't think
so
I was all right
I man one time back in the day and they
can't do this [__] today but on 51 they
will separate you from the ab student
the CD student and just the dumbass
student right so I was in the CD of the
dumbass student category but I always
wanted to be number one at anything I do
so I said please teacher please let me
read out the book we call Impressions
and so she was like I just just love
your wheelpower Patricia I got up in
that group and I tried to read I was so
hard the smart like if you don't get
this [__] out this
group The see like you tried baby you
tried a for for yes any sports growing
up did you play any sports no I was
pregnant too quick okay I tried my
teacher my teacher thought cuz I was so
big and developed you know cuz I had
titties and booties in the sixth grade
he was like you should throw the disc
but at I was like seventh grade you
should throw the disc but I was getting
dick in real life and it was not the
same type of throw so I throw that heavy
ass metal too busy getting ped down back
here huh okay what age what age did you
get pregnant I got pregnant at uh
13 bir at 14 damn 13 and 14 no I got
pregnant at 13 gave birth at 14 got
pregnant at 14 and gave birth at 15 and
did you stay did you stay in did you get
your high school diploma did you stay
schol I got GD I got I jumped out and
started selling drugs drugs okay crack
had just hit the black community and it
was employing everybody in my community
well startup action all right get in on
the ground floor I like it I got in on
the ground
floor okay all right were you making
were you making good money doing that I
making a lot of [__] money and were
you still living at home with your mom
no my mom was off on her own doing her
thing I I moved into a [__] nice ass
apartment I fak my ID and I always had
big titties in a nice shape and I always
act older so I walked in there for me
some check stubs and got my friend
answer the phone at the phone booth and
say I work there and I got an
apartment man that's all right talk
about working the system baby yeah damn
okay all right all right so so you had
the baby you're about 15 you get your
own place I got two babies at 15 two two
babies at 15 you got your own place and
you're moving you're moving a little
action I'm moving a little action what
would you say you were bringing in a
week roughly uh 15 20 $1,000 something
like that I made a lot of [__] a we yeah
I had a partner Jesus Christ we made a
[__] ton of money holy [__] moving
weight guys forget patreon we got to get
in the crack yeah all right
ohra no more all right all right nobody
smoked that [__] anymore it's like
Bitcoin it's over it's it's over you
missed the gold rush on it yeah all
right so you're making 15 20 G's a week
you're doing you're you're doing well
what kind of car were you driving back
then I was driving a uh a 19 I want to
1986 Fleetwood Cadillac and that's back
when drug dealers first came out we had
the big gold chain and everybody had
that Cadillac and mine was pearl white
with flakes in with with u burgundy
material with the soft uh I don't know
what they call that top the soft top
yeah the rag top the rag top oh [__]
youve been there you've been
somewhere you know I don't forgot used
to be a pimp I used to sell crack back
in my day too miss when a white man can
tell you it's a rag top on a go what the
[__] I supposed to know
that so I that's what I drove okay holy
[__] that's a nice car yeah huh so I I
assume that jump was was pretty crazy
you went from nothing to Cadillac in two
years or were you putting any of that
money away were you saving any of it
nobody they didn't teach you how they
didn't teach they don't teach you no
Savings in Hood they teach you to just
be flashy Michael Jordan it just came to
the NBA everybody wanted to join you at
the precipice of every big thing happen
in the black community Michael Jordan
drug dealing just dropped go Michael
Jordan had just dropped his first P well
FUBU was the [__] then fuboo after fubo
for us by us that was like the first big
black designer that we can remember then
we Ease on into Michael Jordan I
remember buy my first P Michael Jordan
you couldn't tell me [__] they was
$59.99 the [__] y'all paying for them
shoes today y'all are ridiculous yeah
damn holy [__] all right so you got a
nice place did you get a house or did
you get another apartment I just got an
apartment who was who was living in that
apartment with you it was me and then I
had my two kids and then my my
sister-in-law my my baby dad really was
my sister-in-law it was somebody El's
husband but my baby daddy's sister uh
was on drugs so I took in her three
girls look you yeah so that's my first
set of crack babies that I raised all
right yeah you sound like make it sound
like they're puppies or something no did
you have any pets did you have any pets
in the house I couldn't afford no pets
with no [__]
children that [__] don't go together
sure huh and how long did that did that
last that you were that you were that
you were selling uh I sold for about 10
10 prob maybe 10 to 12 years damn I sold
it a while this is all pre-c comedy oh
yeah this is way pre- comedy okay I was
I I I always been able to make people
laugh but I was just I was just I'm just
outspoken so I just say crazy [__] uhhuh
but I didn't think I was funny I thought
I was a way better drug dealer you might
have been I mean it sounds like you were
doing pretty well GE a weak that's 80s
money too that's crazy yeah I had I mean
I was living a life I didn't I didn't do
drugs I just party I mean I don't even
think I wasn't even 21 so I was getting
in the club under age I was buying
clothes I was having an apartment we was
just living a life were you were you
guys going on vacations or anything like
that didn't nobody tell me people go on
vacation nothing all right I wish like
hell I had went somewhere I had never I
think the closest vacation was drive
down to Florida and you out of Atlanta
you doing it yeah yeah okay huh and
where was the cash would you put it in
the bank or would it be like in the
house of the wall you can't put no
[__] cash in Bank all right we
were hiding in my friend house I kind of
had a partner when I started to really
ride so we were hiding at his house
hided at my house okay you know I love
that that's crazy you can't walk in the
bank and say I got $80,000 and you black
with with gold around your neck you
going to [__] jail at 17 at damn
right I think I was 16
and you never got pinched she got out
clean right no I went to prison but I
us I asked you about vacation that ain't
no [__] vacation but I got to tell
you this I've told this story 100 times
this my favorite store cuz I couldn't
drive but I wanted a car and I had the
money to buy a car and so I really at
this point I'm raising myself so the
crackhead was like I teach you how to
drive so he would come pick me up in a
Jed or stick at night and he would take
me around 285 and put my two kids in the
back and they be cheering me on and be
in the pass seat smoking crack out of a
pipe and he would that's how I learn how
to
drive from a
crackhead and my kid say tell him to put
his cigarette I put the goddamn crack
pipe down in front of my k i put his
cigarette
out my kids didn't know he was smoking
crack he blow I'm blowing it out the
Wonder my kids going to be a crack in
this system Jesus you talking about
unfit I but I love my kids but I was
unfit and did you were young yeah of
course when you got pinched did you get
to keep some of the money like did you
have them did you have some of the money
when you started in comedy no it all it
all went away oh it all went away you
spend it all on lawyers okay and dumb
[__] and and plus it stops coming in at
that point bur so I did a year for uh
for selling drugs well I I actually I
violated my my probation cuz I I got
caught with my cousin kissing the
[__] in the car so they pinned
the dope on me it really was my dope
people laying up on the hill watching
the whole time with pictures so I ended
up going to prison for a year I mean I
got a year I got five years provation I
was like oh [__] you I'm on top of the
world and that [__] came and got me
while I was at the welfare office
applying for my welfare check jeez damn
wait so you were under surveillance they
they they got you with pictures that's
pretty cool so I when I violated my
probation I had to do a year off the
five years okay and so I did a year in
jail in Atlanta or in in a prison and
then so when you so you started over so
you're starting over yet again well my
baby daddy kind of kept the Trap going
so when I got out I knew enough bigger
drug dealers that were front it's called
front you okay I give you this half a
key you give me this much money you
think you're talking you're talking you
think we don't know what front drugs is
you know what rag top is so let me stop
talking like you don't know the hell you
talking about check this guy for a wire
so I I would get fronted and get back on
my feet but at that okay so you got out
and sold drugs again hell yeah okay I'm
sorry I'm just just trying to pin
timeline down do you think people get
out and just stop I don't know do people
just just cuz you lock a crackhead up
don't mean they ain't going to smoke
again true you're right were there ever
were there ever any uh straight jobs
yeah I met a no uh not I met that's no
you said yes and backpedal real quick
Miss well I met a I met a a guy uh my
husband who I'm still with after 31
years and he he didn't grow up like that
yeah we met him he didn't grow up like
that grew up in the church Mom and Daddy
middle class household so he wasn't
hearing the drug so he's like look you
need to give all this [__] up and then I
ended up working at McDonald's but I
always had a hustling spirit so I
figured out how to uh go into the
register and promote all the food and
steal [__] I was make backing those days
you making $4 an hour that ain't no
[__] money when you come from making
all this money as a drug dealer so I I
was like McDonald ain't going to miss
none of the heavy meals I'm not they not
getting the money for so if you order
something I could now one thing I could
do back in the day add really quick I
add that [__] it's going to be this if
it was cash I hit promo open that R go
in there take the money and give them
their change what were you pulling down
a week to of that a couple hundred bucks
did you ever get knocked doing that no
uhuh damn no I had that [__] damn pay
cuz when you don't just steal from a
corporation like McDonald you get other
people to steal with you so everybody
make a little bit you know somebody
interested in stealing the burgers the
cheese the lce I was interested in the
cash R you guys can keep the fries I got
food stamps I could I could buy that
crap at
Kroger shout out to Kroger that's all
right the Kroger was your grocery store
growing up ah yeah Kroger Piggly Wiggly
you know I'm from the south okay and
where you shopping nowadays where you
food shopping now uh Publix okay nice uh
I still like Walmart you know okay
anywhere and are you going to do it
yourself I do and people be shocked they
like you in the store yeah [__] you in
the
store I got to eat too sure sure sure
they be shocked like you shock for
yourself why am I'm going to pay
somebody to come up here I know how to
do this of course you're not wrong yeah
you can't you know people think cuz you
got money you know money do make you
lazy it do cuz people wait on your hand
and foot if you can if you can afford it
but I don't want all them people in my
house then they be done got a hold to my
husband I can't be following the young
girls I got
vertigo okay you don't want young girls
around the houses what no they titties
set up straight they stuff titter they
don't leak I can't compete with that
stuff hey I respect it yeah start
playing defense yeah I can't I don't
need no nanny my kid take care their
damn s Kevin talking about sheath shout
out to OG sheathy yeah been with us from
Jump Street uhuh and I'll tell you what
what I know they sent you over a pair
back then you probably still got them
they're still fantastic yeah I only had
to throw away one pair cuz I got too fat
for the wasteband but everything else
has been staying for 3 years the most
reliable underwear on the market gang do
yourself a favor get yourself some
sheath again holiday season coming up
you want to make sure you got enough
undies you want durable undies that are
going to last and not leave your leave
your leave your nuts hanging out there
in the breeze You're twigging berries so
get some sheath uh yeah it was created
by us Sergeant Robert Patton sheath with
was made to withstand the heat of the
Iraqi desert so you know it's going to
keep you cool when you're hitting a
treadmill an air conditioned gyms also I
got two pockets one for your one for
your twig and one for your berries
sometimes I put two berries in one
sometimes I put one twig and one Berry I
mix it up you can't you knows what's
going on down here put one in his ear
like it's a headphone uh my
uh it's a long ball Larry uh my D and my
BS feel amazing I call it my sexy
underwear I walk around there I'm
strutting my thing [__] take a shot
at the lady
go to sheath underwear. comom and use
the code garbage and get 20% off your
first order plus sheath sheath
underwear's 100% money back guarantee
that sheath underwear. comom promod
garbage get sheath underwear support the
show support your balls do it yeah Keb
talk about dish plate shout out to
displate baby yeah what are you guys
using out there you're still using old
paper posters like a bozo like a stoner
all dog ears putting putting pins in the
wall and stuff like that you're going to
get jammed up on a deposit get dis plate
metal posters they go on the wall in
about two seconds it's all magnet
technology plus they got them licensing
deals you got Marvel you got Star Wars
you got your favorite shows all the cool
stuff do yourself a fever uh yeah it's
fantastic not only will dis blades so
cool in your home they'll also make
great gifts you give them to the kitties
you you got nieces and nephews you want
to wow your niece and nephew hit them
with a GD displate baby a gosh darn
displate though it'll knock their socks
or'll be going to school bragging you
know what I mean maybe maybe even
[__] land a little lady or something
come over check out the
display get all the neighborhood kids
riled up uh your poster comes with
everything you'll need to hang it
immediately just pop just pop the
included magnet on your wall set the
display to it and you're all set here
you go here's the turkey thank you
display for sponsoring our show we love
you use code garbage or click the link
in our description you'll to pull that
back use the code garbage or click the
link in our description to get yourself
and your friends displates up to 30% off
there you go this is a special discount
that's only available for a limited time
your discount will be automatically
applied to your cart do it who's who's
living with you now you and your husband
no me and my husband and I have custody
of my niece kids so I have four nukes my
last set of crack babies okay and how
old are they uh 11 I mean I'm sorry 15
12 11 and I think nine and then I have
my 24y old daughter who writes on the
show she lives there okay and my son
Jumba who y'all saw get drunk at at the
thing yeah him he lives there too okay
okay is it a big house I just built it
177,000
[Applause]
ft that's a big house there you go you
live in New York or
anything we all live
here [__] a 10 is bigger than some [__]
I 177,000 square fet and I did it I you
know I didn't hire a contractor my
husband like you're crazy I saved the
cash I did the budget and I said this is
what I want so and I said well if I go
out and get a contractor I'm going to
have to give him 20% of the budget that
could be a nicer faucet for me and so
I'm a DIY so that's what I do I love to
DIY before all of this my career really
took off so I was like I'm I said my
husband said I said we did the first
season of Miss Pat I said I'm not coming
back to Indiana I can't take no more
snow I can't take no I got to be around
allp that's where you were you were in
Indiana 15 years with my husband he
worked for General Motors okay and so we
move uh I came and shot the first season
of the Miss patch show in Atlanta I
called my husband uh like uh remember
that movie Harlem kns he said ain't
coming back Sunshine [__] so good so I
said I ain't coming back I said I'm not
I said you can pack up you can retire
and leave I said but I'm not coming back
and so I said what do you what can I do
to get you to retire early and come to
Atlanta he said well I don't want to
live in the city I want some land I
found seven acres for $400 and something
thousand it was a house setting there
3500 F feet I knocked that [__] down
had knock sh and I hired an architect
and I went
forward crazy it's up now we should be
moving in next month yeah there you go
there you go look at it killing it
what's your hold sorry what about that
your Custom Design the house right I did
C what's your favorite thing in the
house you're like I have to have this
kind of new money [__] oh new so
something's in there you don't have a
17,000 foot house without some new money
[__] in there miss so I bought this
faucet and it it's called I think it's
called winter SP I don't know uh let me
show it to you yeah so the faucet is
$5,500 a faucet faet a faucet in the
kitchen in the bathroom faucet K okay so
I I have to get the name I don't
remember the name of but it's a custom
faucet and I've just I was going on Tik
Tok when I said oh my God I got to have
that so I didn't buy one I bought two
are they both where are they both in the
kitchen well so I have a the kitchen is
two islands two big old gigantic Islands
nice and so I have one on one Island and
I have one on the island that the kids
sit
at dude two double Islands I got double
Islands so when you started comedy were
you in Indiana I was in Atlanta you Bor
and raised and my husband job General
Motors closed in Atlanta and transferred
Indiana he didn't want we didn't we we
didn't have the money for him to take
the B out so then you started you
started touring and everything from from
out of Indiana yeah and then so you're
grinding it out the whole time yep I get
on The Bob and Tom Show and get a whole
new audience to the Bob and Tom Show got
it and then you get the Miss Pat show
and that that's when everything started
to change that's when everything changed
gotcha that's when and I never went back
to Indiana what year is this uh five
years ago what is five years ago crazy
yeah 2018 17 something yeah so I started
pitching the show around 2015 I did Joe
Rogan podcast and Mark Mar Hollywood
immediately called and said we want to
give you a TV show so I had all these
Studio meetings you know I'm just a
little girl from the West I don't want
to hear this cop AC crap you know what
I'm saying don't be up here wasting my
time so you know I don't all these big
wigs are rolling out throwing everything
at you like don't be wasting my time now
yeah so I go and and I go to um I go to
um run Howard studio and um one of his Z
heard me tell my story on on Joe Rogan
podcast he said I couldn't get out of
the car he immediately called me his
name is John Rattler we we family now
and I hated him I cuz you know what I'm
from the sou and you know my mama did re
raise us somewhat decent and he put his
foot on the table and I wanted to
[__] choke him
out how dare you put your feet on my on
furniture that is so disrespectful sure
wait was this at your house or no it was
at their office it's not even your table
it wasn't even my T and I wanted to kill
him you know my son used to when I moved
to Indiana my son really I don't care
who you date I don't I I'm not going to
say I don't see color cuz I do we a
[__] culturalist different let's be
honest you you me you were the same you
know I mean okay you date a black woman
is totally different from dating a white
woman of course my son bring home these
white girls in Indiana cuz we lived in
an all white neighborhood and and I
don't have a problem with white women
but white kids ain't raised like black
kids like I come home from Taco Bell cuz
I you know I'm working at Taco Bell
trying to make it as a ComEd I walk in
he got this beautiful blond little white
girl feet laid in his lap and she don't
even [__] speak to me so I walk in I
say white [__] go home you a got no
maners go the [__] home I walk in you
speak to me sure hello how you doing and
get your feet off my [__] couch you
white
[__] so I told him I said if you going
to date white women you need to give
them OJ book on how to
D I'm sorry that's the wrong word okay
how to a negro a black person you can
edit it we have to bleep it for YouTube
purposes but sure I I I understand the
sense dat a black person you don't just
not speak to some black mama sure
walking in from a long day at Taco I say
yeah I say you Sayo get a white girl
that know how to say hello to your black
mother were you still working at Taco
Bell when when you got these meetings
when you were getting these meetings
[__] Jesus yeah so so that's amazing
what happened was I'm at the comedy club
in Indiana called Mor mores at the time
and so one of the comedian was like you
know um I cannot think of I always
cannot think of this guy name and I hate
it this one podcast his first Stu white
boys were popping off with podcast shout
out to it
g you said it sister let's go dang it I
cannot think of his name and I hate it I
can't think of his name he was a
podcaster he was a podcaster he was um
with uh Eddie Eddie if Yeah Eddie if
that's the first podcast I ever done and
so one of the comedians said Eddie if is
looking for somebody with some real
stories I told him he should interview
you I said to do what he said podcast
what the [__] is a pod I'm sorry no
what what the hell is a podcast he was
like you got to go do it Miss P I'm
telling you a take off so I did it and I
killed it and and I thought it was weird
cuz they was doing some of the crazy
stuff at eddf podcast and I was out of
place but I did it and it was funny
immediately all the white boys started
calling me so my the guy who ran the
club he said if Joe Rogan call you
you're going to make it so I said who is
Joe
Rogan so when he showed me the picture I
said the guy from uh Fear Factor what
happened to his H it's cuz I didn't know
the comedy world you know sure that yeah
that comedy you know the white part of
the comedy world so you can say yeah so
I started doing all these podcast and so
Mark Marin called before Joe Rogan
called okay no Joe Rogan called first I
can't remember either one and we ended
up shooting Eddie uh uh we ended up
shooting uh what's that show the standup
show about stories Ari
I met ARA we sat in the uh we sat in the
park and I said the weirdest crap to him
I was like I didn't know it was a lot of
Jews I thought it was only Jesus because
we only had that one on the wall and so
we sit in the par and all of these
people walking around with them little
curly fries down their face okay and so
he out there explaining to me they're
different from him and I'm like I'm
confused uhhuh sure I didn't know I just
my mama told me it was just one and it
was Jesus Christ so I was blown away you
were told Jesus Christ was the only
Jewish guy Jewish guy and then you see
then you see all these atics walking
around with Ari and you have to okay all
right yeah so so I go back I say did
y'all know was a lot of Jewish people in
this world cuz I'm
soive I took it a lot better than y'all
y'all look like Y'all Scared no no I
just took me a minute
also so
so
also to be shocked there's more than one
Jewish guy to
me I was I like how you reported back
then all your black family like you know
there's there's more there's more more
than one Jewish I don't know nothing
about entertainment sure
so we shoot we shoot the show and I do a
episode with Mark Mar and Joe Rogan and
uh Joe Rogan had just did it Mark Mar he
no Mark Mar was telling Joe you got to
have own so just so happened they kind
of dropped around the same time and I
got a book deal off of Mark Mar and
Hollywood just came knocking and I
didn't know what to say to Hollywood so
I said I'm just going to be myself and
that's what they purchased was me that's
amazing well I shouldn't say purchase
but yeah
sure that's what they invested in they
invested in they invested in Miss Pat
yeah and then they allowed me to be who
I am that's amazing and it took off I
love I love those stories where it's
like you were prob killing for I mean
you're so F you're so naturally funny so
you're probably killing for you know for
a long time in obscurity and then all of
a sudden it's like you're so ready and
all these you know all these things
start happening it's great well you know
I'm the good part about I was a touring
comedian sure I was out there working on
my hour uh or two hours and and I was I
was really ready of course yeah and get
the call I get the call and and I knew
what I wanted the show to be and we
ended up going through two two writers
and we found that third writer the great
you know the blessing the part the
blessing part about the Miss Pat show
that show got dropped three times by Fox
Fox picked that show up three times we
went through three writers and the third
writer said listen Fox you got something
here 22 year old kid Jordan Cooper he
said y'all need to let her be her and
this is how this show is going to be
successful so Fox agreed to sell it to
streaming platforms and Hulu bought it
great I Hulu bu and the first thing come
on my word is the n word that man said
hell no not over
here he trying to get dropped
again my head they dropped it I think I
scared the Z over at Hulu so bad with
the content but it was so funny I'm a
black mama I'm a mama that a lot of
people know I said he don't understand
me and and he's not going to pick up the
show and I knew it in my heart he was
not going to pick up the show but I
never not believe that the show would
get picked up somewhere and so bet plus
came knocking and I love telling this
story I had no no idea that it was a bet
plus cuz I don't watch bet at the time I
didn't and I was like where they get a
plus from and so my my co-creator who's
into TV he said hey they have less than
a million subscribers we're GNA die and
I said we're not going to die I said one
thing I know about crack two things you
ain't never seen a commercial for is
crack and Waffle House and they out
sells everything they're I said if we
create crack and Waffle House we got
them
I mean you should be running a Fortune
500 company it's crazy and they love it
we created cracked
WiFi dude my head I know and so we in
our fourth season we've been nominated
for Emmy twice bet first Emmy nomination
that's amazing congratulations and we
got nominated last year and this year
great and you know we didn't win and
wasn't even about to win for me it was
me sitting at the eny a little old black
girl from the inner city of Atlanta with
eighth grade education up with her my
name is Miss Pat see me up against Ted
lasso um uh so many other great shows
and I was like I don't even need the
image he working at Taco Bell four years
ago or three years ago I'm in the gang I
mean you cannot deny that I'm a part of
this situation I might be on a smaller
platform but I'm here to wrestle baby
now roll your sleeves up and let's get
to it we got cracked the bag yes and T L
Ted leso one but I didn't even care
because I was in the mix yeah it's
amazing un and I got to go to the enemy
the food was good I put some snack some
a purse did you yeah I ate my ass off
that night what was the food at what's
the food at the Emmy um fancy
[__] but it wasn't it wasn't unseasoned
fancy you know how you can go play like
who the hell eat this MH it wasn't that
t it would good we would have ate good
that
night you're walking around the Em's
eating shrimp cocktail telling Jason
sedus to take his shoes off his
chair that's I don't like Shri K I don't
like that raw but they they had some
steak strip sandwich to die for and I
didn't want to seem too greedy so I was
telling the people who didn't want to
eat who didn't want to drink I was like
go get another sandwich go get another
sandwi okay oh sorry what is your
favorite restaurant what's yeah a nice
restaurant you're going you're going out
to in there you're celebrating it's a
birthday where you going if I'm here in
if I'm in La it's uh crustation
crustation yeah if you want to be fancy
but semi fancy is Chick-fil-A I talk
about semi fancy while I do love a good
Chick-fil-A let's get into some qes you
you've already turned the game upside
down which I love we love it what a
come- up story that's it's unbelievable
uh I have one where we're still kind of
in the vanin you talked about the house
the faucet has was there any other big
dumb purchase you made when you got your
first B
check from Comedy
uh yeah or that you were like look back
like I didn't need like a jet ski crazy
vacation anything like that well I took
the family to Hawaii I think the big I
took like 20 some people to Hawaii but
you you rolled Deep by the way I we were
with you on the cruise you said you
brought 2 22 people You2 black people to
a cruise of 3,000 white people we had to
put the flavor in the building
you think I going to listen to John
melan cap every damn
night are you crazy I say Cypher s can
you blacken it
up next thing I know we were like wait
Sur your family came up and took over
the stage at one point yeah it was great
I think the I think I ain't gonna say
it's D but I just wanted it cuz you know
I like walking in the store with no bra
right and my wig M it up I don't like I
just when I go shopping I want you to
treat me like you would treat somebody
who's rich so you don't know me you
don't recognize me so I walked in Chanel
one day and um you know I I like Chanel
I do and I said I want that bag right
there immediately security start
scrambling red team go red team go you
know I don't I can't fault them because
people are running out of stores with
high-end bags but I didn't care I just
pulled out my American Express card and
I said I'll take that they said do you
do know this is uh $122,000 without
taxes I said yeah and be sure to put the
taxes on there cuz I like our
president so I P spent a little bit over
$113,000 for a pocketbook okay how long
ago was this I have a couple of them now
yeah there you go see like Chanel I do I
like high but I've always like highend
bags and when I couldn't afford them of
course I got the best knockoffs but
now now that I sell tickets I know how
and Gucci and Louis Vuitton Phi you know
I don't want nobody knocking off my
tickets so I don't knock off they stuff
sure I respect the game I get it I like
it I like it okay H all right what uh
why you why we're on bags what kind of
luggage do you have you travel a lot you
got nice you go nice luggage uh I have a
few uh Louis Vuitton luggage but you
know that's like vacation you got the
Louis Vuitton luggage yeah but that's
only for vacation like when I'm doing
gigs and I'm taking my merch with me I
just buy bass cuz boy d don't care how
they break the wheels off of it yeah
they get all but I'm Petty you break my
luggage I call in a
claim they give me $130 all the time you
tear my stuff up you going to give me
the money to replace it and sometime my
sister be looking at me like oh you can
AF I don't care yeah Delta can afford it
too yeah and I be like it was $300 and I
make me a receipt and I send it to Delta
is that you you fly Delta you're you're
a Delta I'm a Delta I'm a you got to be
we're Delta as well I'm 360 what's
360 oh that's that's the that's a butts
above uh diamond right yeah woo all
right Platinum flying up front I assume
always okay the day I can't afford to
fly up front of I don't know what I'm
going to do in the bag we're the same
way we're blowing all of our money on
First Class tickets but it feels nice I
can't I haven't been in the back in so
long and I tell you how I became first
class because after I started pitching
the show everybody was flying me on
Delta and next thing I know that was
always first class I was like wait a
minute this is nice you ain't got no fat
dude that's in the middle that can't fit
between us I resent that yeah I I I mean
I haven't been a person in the middle of
me in a long time sure sure so I I like
I'm I'm spoiling myself I feel like I
worked hard should and I'm I'm that's
what I'm going to do I I love that
that's that's that's great what kind of
perfume do you like use perfume yeah but
I can't never pronounce the name of
them b baraki or something like that
okay I don't know yeah huh okay yeah ask
my sister what's the name of the perfume
I buy okay somebody gave it to me for a
gift and then I Googled it was $300 a
bottle so I I love it cuz you got a nice
you do have a nice uh Aroma to you thank
you I watched this morning fragrance
fragrance is the word I looking for you
shower at night or shower in the morning
oh no I cannot take no shower at night
no shower at night shower in the morning
yeah I have to sleep on it dirty because
if I don't don't I wait I I
oversleep okay okay I over sleep when
I'm clean okay okay what the f you know
I was telling somebody that I was like
crazy I never heard that s but I kind of
get it I get what you're saying you're
too comfortable you're you over sleep
yeah I don't like showering that and
then if my husband going to do something
I'll shower at night but if we he going
to break you off a pie yeah ain't no
sense of wasting no water if you ain't
going to do nothing
you might as well sleep on today's and
then wash it all off tomorrow sure sure
how's the shower at the new house you
had the custom built I assume yes it's U
two showerheads what four showerheads
some sprayers it's got um heated floors
heated floors and it's got a it's a
steamer wow that's all right his and her
sinks in the in the bathroom uh two
sinks or one sink no two sinks and two
toilets two toilet two toilets yeah
don't know I don't want smell that mess
no more I want to be in peace is the
toilet in like another like well he's on
one side and I'm on the other side and I
have my closet and his closet is down
the other Hall walk-in closet tyon uh my
closet is probably half of this room
[__] Miss Pat's doing it right I love it
how about the how about the bed
king-size bed KingSize bed yeah okay I
have he I have a room with my husband
and then when I don't like him I go to
my own bedroom so I have another bedroom
you got two bedrooms well I I have three
Masters on the main so I made one of the
master mind when I don't want to hear
him snowing and my husband is on a Zing
field like you okay and he you burp he
pass gas and he burp and that mess with
light a that would tear a roof off a
house oh my God and I'm like dude I
think I just rather have you fat than a
smell cuz it's like it's like a toxic it
smells like sewage yes it's worse than
sewage bad and then it's silent I don't
know why Z it make it silent yeah but
he's lost like 50 lbs I'm like when do
you you get off this yeah yeah yeah I
know and then he get mad at you and I'm
telling you the air freshen won't even
kill it a breeze don't stand a chance no
I mean I'm black so I burn incense right
you know they got some incense called
black [__] so I you never seen those I
hav't seen Google it I'm not lying to
you it's just going to take me to
Pornhub no no it's not no it's not I
can't believe put in black [__] incense
I'm telling you so I burned them and it
still don't kill his
odor
yeah she wasn't Depot yeah you can get
it on home you can get it on Amazon you
should buy some I don't think my wife
might get upset about it but all right
well they might have some for the white
too you can change the name on the
label hey pussy's [__] where I come
from it all pink on the
inside and it all going to piss on
you
I don't know what you talk about your
wife got babies no oh well wa do she
have a baby she going to leak in the
front and the back Jesus oh my
God also one of the things you do Google
black [__] incense it's in your you you
something from you pops up it's in your
Reddit it's in your Reddit I swear to
God this the second thing the first yeah
black [__] incense I think I told
somebody else that story but yeah I I
burn them all the time you can buy them
on the
street
what y'all laughing at you can't buy
that
Walmart this is this is some Hood stuff
uh-huh sure all right all right how many
you get the body oil too how many
pillows you keep on the bed uh probably
six to eight and how many do you sleep
with you sleep on your side on your back
on your stomach well I'm top heavy so I
take my bra off and get my bra get my my
top pillow okay and then I put one
between my legs and up under my head all
right one between your leg legs I like
that a fan on when you sleep no my
husband do I hate cold air I like to be
hot crazy and my husband would has a
Silling fan on the air conditioner on
and another fan I said dude if you that
hot you might be about to blow
up he be sweating in his sleep you sleep
with the TV on uh he don't he like the
dart but I'm I've been robbed a couple
times I fig you had a TV on so somebody
say get up and you open up your eye you
can at least I ified in the dark you
don't know who robbed you sure
okay I've never heard of for security
purposes you keep anything by the bed
for security
purposes no he do he keep a shotgun and
all kind I don't I'm a convicted fell if
I shoot somebody I'm going to jail even
in selfdefense I usually keep water
snacks you know if I roll over and
eat I keep stuff to eat while he
shooting them I'm going to eat and watch
TV do you guys eat in bed hell
yeah you know we lazy now we got that
bed to let your head up so you can burp
and eat and when you digest lay back lay
back down you have a you have a fridge
in the bedroom and my new one yes you do
full size I have a full size mini what
the [__] no not no it's like the Delta
Lounge in there it's what it's going to
look
like I have three refrigerators in my
kitchen cuz I have a pantry that's
almost the same size of the refrigerat I
mean of the kitchen so I have a I have
three dishwashers and three
refrigerators three dishwash Jesus mhm
man you're going to you host all the
family functions I assume Thanksgiving
CRA they not coming to my house feel my
stuff yeah but I'm going to cook for
friends you cook for friends so no
family is allowed over not much not much
like my sister just uh my sister just uh
she my sister crackhead so she was in a
rehab she got put out cuz she said they
put me out for cuz I smoked a little
Craig
generally FR upon it's a little bit
what's a little crack between friends
but you're supposed to be at the rehab
right so I just don't let my family come
over sure smart smart okay all right all
right that new house have a have a pool
it do have a pool okay they have a pool
they have a inground trampoline inground
trampoline really yes hot tub it has a a
hot tub on it it has two Sun shelves in
the pool inground pool I in oh yeah I
ain't doing that white trash put the
deck around on top of the grass pool
everybody floa down the street I ain't
doing
that that white trash I want my in the
ground dude I can't get my breath uh
okay is it is that freshwat or a
saltwater pool
saltwater doing what are you driving
around in now what kind of car you
got go ahead it's something nice I have
a 2020 3G wagon w
talk to your account you can write that
whole thing off cuz it's over 6,000 lb
yeah damn Miss Pat playing checkers out
or chess out here housekeeper at the
house I I do have a housekeeper but not
at the house she just coming clean she
she's not staying there uhhuh okay all
right but we clean most of the time my
husband is military so you know keeps it
tight yeah he keeps it pretty tight do
you open your eyes under water in the
pool for what
what I ain't no damn
fish can you open your eyes upon the
wall who would do that I do
it I want to know what's happening down
there is that why your eyes
gray you burnt your pupils out you nosy
boy white people show your
nosy I not opening my damn no salt water
no
chlorine you dead knows
it no a man I don't know anybody that
might have been my favorite response
ever dude my sides honestly
hurt how do you like your steak cook I
don't E I don't like steak okay how do
you how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken I like rotisserie chicken how do
you get your how do you like your eggs
cooked Scramble with cheese all right I
hate a fried egg fried egg remind me of
being poor okay cuz my mama used to
fried eggs all time like hey just
scramble them like they do on The Young
and the Restless I don't want no damn
fried egg I hate a fried EG okay I hate
stuff that remind me of being really
poor like I if I go down the aisle and
they're spaming polish meat it upsets me
I can't eat sunbean white bread cuz I
ate it as a kid and it stick to the roof
of your mouth so back in the day it will
make you choke yeah so I don't eat some
I don't eat white bread okay what do you
like now multigrain yeah wheat most gra
all right what kind of toothpaste are
you rocking at the house uh something
with a uh whitening in it I I I am
allergic to offbrand stuff because I
grew up so poor and my husband is
military so he love like he won't buy
Oreos but he'll buy Twist and Shout and
we argue all the time you got Oreo money
what are we doing you got a 17,000 foot
house get the [__] Oreos he would buy
can he will buy canned goods with No
Label because they be in a little basket
at the grocery store guess what this is
and I'm like if you got one more time to
bring that crap to my house and give me
flashback I'm killing everybody wait so
hold just by a random can and not know
what it is he don't care he don't care
he don't care I mean he's he used to be
really bad like offbrand uh potatoes or
offbrand uh green beans I I cannot eat
offbrand food it bothers me you don't go
for any of that if we were if we came
over to the house and you offered us a
glass of water what would it be would it
be out of the tap would it be a br would
it be a bot it would be a bottle it' be
a bottle you got sparkling I love
sparkling when you go to when you go you
put um uh Crystal Light in It's banging
damn who you're doing Crystal Light and
like pelino or something that's pretty
good that is that is the duality of
class and trash right there that's
[__] nuts when you go to a restaurant
and they say what kind of water do you
want you get you're getting bottle P
won't drink tap water let me tell you
why I won't drink tap water so when I
was a little girl they didn't care
anything about the poor and poor don't
have to be no color just poor so they
just take you on the Fe free field trips
and one of the free field trips in
Atlanta was to the Atlanta Waterworks
and they take it hey black kids po kids
this is our water made and you just see
turds soaking and I was like what the
hell didn't they take come on over here
and they take you a fresh glass or what
I was like but we were just over there
so
that I hate tat water because they tug
me on that field trip every year to show
me that we drinking leftover TB yeah I
don't like that I I can't know that yes
and so I was like why would you do that
to us so I I I I can't drink tap water
were you EA in the car do you guys EA in
the car now were you eatting the wag car
yes I do favorite fast food Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A do you do the drive-thru or
do you go in oh it's too many Christians
on the
inside my son used to I I love
Chick-fil-A so much I made my son work
at Chick-fil-A in Indiana and when he
quit cuz I had a 30% discount so when he
quit damn when pretty good dude 30% when
he quit I was so I wanted to beat him
and I said why did you quit my favorite
job he said cuz it was no longer my
pleasure ah cuz that's been their
pleasure it's been my pleasure and he
had worked out through all through High
School H will you get cash back when you
go and you make a purchase with your
debit card will you get cash back from
the register no no okay none of my CS
you can get cash on I don't have a pin
number you don't have a debit card I got
one but I don't have a pen number to it
never sent one so if you rob me you take
me to the pen I'm like you going to take
me to your house you going to take me
inside the bank I don't know no paying
numbers so no ATMs you use all all all
credit cards or or your debit card well
yeah I just use American Express play
with them if you want
to I know exactly what you mean yeah
American Express will figure it the [__]
out they are not the one they're not
Visa they're not MasterCard they
American is Express and they ask you for
all they money within 30 days yeah they
do they want it you don't never hear
nobody they hack my American Express
card you got one you can go somewhere
true that's so true no one's American
Express card gets hacked you can go
somewhere and not be satisfied and they
would give you your money money back
yeah yes all big purchases make on an
American Express I make everything on
American Express don't play with me
don't play with me play with Jesus cuz
he came here and died for
you okay is that what you so American
Platinum the I'm Platinum yeah the
silver one yeah what kind of mayo at the
house you use Miracle Whip or do you use
helmond we black okay what's that mean
don't you don't mess with not a lot
that's that's a white thing but if if
I'm making potato salad it's Miracle
will okay yeah but we don't do no may we
don't my husband hate May and you just
don't black people that's May is not our
thing I mean we cook with it or we you
know but my husband makes him
vomit is the potato Sal always homemade
or will you have potato Sal from the
store we try always homemade so much
better okay can you cook are you a good
cook no I'm not no but I have a hell of
a sto I just bought yeah I have all wo I
have all wolf appliances wolf that's a
real knife what about the cookware
what's the cookware Wolf the cookware's
wolf too the pans damn damn Miss Pat thr
around Ming some [__] cash shoes off
in the house shoes on
uh the new house off shoes are off and
is that in is that enforced like if
somebody came over and didn't take off I
have I have mittens and stuff at the
door for you whatever what holy [__] so
if we came over you'd say shoes off put
on a pair shoes off yeah either put some
uh booties on oh over the shoes yeah cuz
I have a hwood floors what about bare
feet if I came in and hadli if your feet
don't stay okay are they real hardwood
floors they're real I didn't do any um I
don't I'm old school so I didn't do any
of that vinyl stuff I did it in the
basement but I definitely didn't do it
upstairs up the the first two levels is
all wood it's all hardwood is there a
third level yes 17,000 sare F feet if it
wasn't it be the size of the [__]
white house yeah it's it's all do you
have an elevator I do shut up no you
don't what holy [__] dud a home elevator
is not that
expensive it's not that cheap either
it's not cheap
either holy [__] okay you're the first
you're the first person to have an
elevator on the show I'm okay so I'm 51
and I don't like stairs cuz I'm fat my
husband fat my kids fat everybody
fat so I figure I I I don't ever say
I've never heard someone call their kids
fat and I'm here for it everything out
of her mouth's funny it's crazy it's
crazy so I don't try you know I'm just
going to keep it real I don't say my
forever home because hey I might get too
big to live in that little neighborhood
I live around 12 little white people and
it's not gated it's just a regular
little Community what the Texas was
great and I got seven acres so I figit
so you're living in a world where
there's even more success like you're
like I I could level up from this house
oh yes I live in a regular neighborhood
I I live in Indiana I lived in a
homeowner association I [__] hated
them people home they don't want you to
paint your house they don't want you to
put a gay out who you can't tell me what
to do with my house so I just said I'm
going to a regular community and I did
and I just tore the house down and that
was the most action those little 12
white people had in over 30
years I can tell you this have nothing
has ever been stolen from my property if
unless a contract took it no if you pull
up on my property my little lady Belinda
cross the street M Pat somebody out here
do they supposed to be out here with
baby they going my neighbors don't play
my neighbors do not play they're old
they're nosy and they ain't got nothing
El to do but call the
police I I've had thousands of dollars
laying out there on the ground never got
tow it away really but I do have a lot
of cameras too there you go you got to
have the cameras I have 26 cameras on my
house cuz I have three k Corso dogs so
they have their own house those are yeah
those are the those things are big
they're big dog yeah they about 10 and
something pounds a piece so they have
their own house I buil them a 600 foot
house it's bigger than my apartment yeah
what's in the dog's house and I'm not an
elevator no three refrigerators they two
islands sushi chef they have a they have
a wash and dryer they have a full
kitchen with a with a refrigerator cuz
my husband feed them raw so everything's
done out there pretty much can if they
have yeah yeah they caged in on the
outside they can come out and chill and
they can go back they have heat in there
and they have cable Wi-Fi and TV oh what
shows that like
they like Restless Miss
pcho holy [__] that's crazy they have
their own TV and everybody comeing they
be like what this the dog house and it's
fully brick it look just like the main
house I love that that's adorable that's
cute they they cage a custom if they had
tried to pitch that on an episode of
cribs they would be like no one's going
to no one's going to buy this we can't
we can't use this what are the dogs
names uh Zeus Sheba and K uh uh Zeus
Sheba and Cone cone okay classy yeah do
you know how to use chopsticks n no I'm
black I just use
fork okay have you ever left a bad Yelp
review now I don't write reviews but I
get my assistant to go I don't be
spelling too
fast it take me a minute thermostat
therat my mind don't click that quick MH
you brush your teeth in the
shower who do that a lot of people do
you pee in the shower yeah pee in the
shower but who brush their teeth in the
shower lot of people some people yeah I
ain't never heard of
that so I I guess y'all don't use
washcloths either no I do we use
washcloths I grew up I grew up using
washcloths is that what you use now is
washcloths hell yeah you well how you
not going to get this the crust out your
booty hole if you don't use you GNA
stick your you bet oh my
God you back there up there making a
crap sandwich will you use the will you
use the soap the shampoo and the and the
and the conditioner that's in the hotel
sometimes in the shower in the you know
they have it in there I steal it too
like they got high in you take it home
sure I I'm saying the ones that are like
they have the pumps in the shower so the
per the the perfume what's the name of
the perfume she told you oh I have it
right here so the perfume that I used we
was just in Miami right and so I noticed
it was the lotion to the perfume and the
lotion cost like $70 I was like well D
this hotel balling that's not a what
that's not a Red Roof in where were you
staying I was staying at the um I don't
know it was I IHG property okay so it
was really nice it was nice and I'm at
the one here in New York now but when I
when I realize I said do y'all realize
this a perum that I wear and I ain't
gonna lie a few people in my in my group
now I was going to just pump it out that
was you know I was going to unscrew it
and pour it in a water bottle just to be
still in the lotion damn that is some
trashy ass [__] I didn't do it but my
friend they took like eight water
bottles of that
lotion going room to room bur bur so
it's like $300 for the perfume but it's
like $80 for the about $10 for the body
wash and 80 for the lotion man I didn't
do it I was like I can afford this but
you know I was going to you thought
about it well I was going to just pour
it over in the water but pumping it was
too much work for me
did you get it though like did did you
did you receive it no I didn't I didn't
want none I just let them sto so they
weren't doing it at your behest no but
you know what I used to do before I made
a lot of money my thing was when um I
would go on tour like uh with big bigger
comedians they would put me in nice
hotels I will always steal the towers oh
my God the hill to the towers Marriott
you get fancy they thick as hell and I
stole so many towels that I Supply my my
the girl who did my hair beauty salon my
friend house my son house every week I
would take an empty suitcase and I would
just steal the towers that's insane
they're really
nice I don't do it anymore wait so
there's there's a beauty salon that's
just all Hilton towels
yeah the girl who used to do my hair
just all Hilton towel what what are the
towels like now are they monogramm no
they all raggedy now cuz I don't steal
them anymore no no I mean
your house at your house oh no I just
buy regular Towers I like to shop at
Ross I'm a very discounted type person
you like a deal yeah I like a deal I
like a deal now I I hit go on some
expensive stuff sometime but you like a
deal how many times will you use a towel
oh once once that's it and it goes in
the hamper yeah okay some people use it
for a whole week I can't do that one one
shot it's done same thing with the
washcloth or will the washcloth stay
stay in the shower no I I no I one one
time one time wow you like a robe you do
robes I'm too fat for robes I don't have
make on my size KY when's the last time
you wash your towel we're going to move
on this shows we're talking to Miss Pat
you reuse your towel I mean well you're
going to never
talk they weak that is
disgusting you putting all that dead
skin back on you it's my skin but it's
nasty it's my skin and I want to keep so
you you go so you go to the bathroom and
you use the toilet sitting down you
going to leave all that flake on the
toilet because you got a whole week of
flakes yeah I yes we you white so you
can't see the danger that you in my I'll
give you that I'll give you that that's
nasty a week's not crazy Google the what
when a towel should be replaced once a
day if you got enough towel that is high
out of every shower just throw it in the
washer that means I got to have seven
towels how many do you have I don't know
two two three yeah about four I think
how many do you have you got to have 48
well I have a lot of towels I'd saying
every three days every three days I'm
over that if we're being honest I've
never even come close because you know
you never wash your body completely
clean so sometime you get out and you
wipe your butt and you still getting
excess stuff sure sure and that is on
that Tower so you flip it over and
you're putting it back on you I know
yeah I'm not you're not wrong Miss Pat
I'm I'm picking up what you're putting
down
okay you sneak sneak snacks into the
movies hell yeah that stuff is expensive
and I tell the kids don't pop the soda
until action part come
boomp what's your go-to movie snack will
you get the popcorn there I love the
nachos okay I love woman after my heart
shout out to the nacho I love the nacho
okay okay I mean I'm pretty I mean have
you ever seen
UFO black people don't see UFOs I get so
tired of white people asking me this it
ain't real
y'all stop trying to make these people
real they not real cuz if they were real
the government will be making them pay
taxes yeah Intergalactic bucks yeah
thank you it ain't real I mean damn I've
never heard only white people see UF fo
M have you ever been ghost hunting or
have you ever seen a ghost why I don't
even go to the graveyard to visit the
dead don't nobody want to hear your
Lively problems okay when I see people
at the grave I'm like why you messing
with them dead people sure let them rest
the most I ever went to the graveyard is
back in the day with my baby daddy cuz
he was married and he didn't have no
money so he would take me to the
graveyard we would have sex out there
but I figur at that time the ghostes was
getting it on
too sex in the graveyard man all the
time I got pregnant with my sex Second
Son in the graveyard Jesus does he know
that yeah you got a dead
eye brain
too I feel like I passed out at some
point I swear to god dude my head hurts
dude how old were you when I I got like
one or two more how old were you uh the
first time you had Lobster and how old
were you the first time you had you got
your
passport oh the first time I got my
passport my friend took me to uh stugart
Germany for a gig so I had to be maybe
about 27 28 okay and because I'm a
convictor fon so I thought I couldn't
get a passp and he it's funny because
after I did the third season of missp
pass show he pulled up the contract I
went all the way the Stewart Germany for
$500 damn when was the first time you
had Nutella what the hell is
Nella that booie peanut butter oh I
don't eat that mess my daughter eat that
I don't eat no Nutella just give me
Jiffy I like the little man with the
with the little shorts on Peter P Peter
Pan and I don't like nuts in them either
cuz I ain't got no back teeth so I don't
like nuts in my peanut
butter uhhuh and the first time I had
Lobster it had to be when I first um uh
first when everybody was going to Red
Lobster back in the day sure but they a
e Lobster that's just some stuff they
done created yeah that's not that's like
grown in a lab or something I when I
when we before we got on the cruise I
decided to treat everybody to a dinner
in Miami because they came on the cruise
with me so I treated everybody to um to
uh uh Prime yeah oh they still talking
about it they like can we just go back
to Prime it's expensive that's I mean
that what was that that Bill's up there
it was that 22 of 23 of you at Ocean
Prime or whatever how much you think I
spent four grand yeah that's exactly
what I spent that wasn't expensive to me
what was funny because I didn't tell
them that I was picking up the bill it
was just hey we going on a cruise
appreciation so everybody sat down and
they was like we we we we we not going
to eat yeah about I had some Nutella on
the right here they was like we just G
to go up the street after this is over I
said I'm paying oh my God came from
everywhere Prime is so good that's funny
damn I mean what do you think Kippy
she's I mean she broke the game she's
Stone Cold trash but I [__] love her
who
trash you a damn lie I got blue craw
Blue
Shield I ain't no Medicaid no more this
vagina has got good health care I've
never had someone drop their health care
is a FX I ain't I got two Health carees
one from sag and one from Odyssey I
ain't no trash I'm doing good my vagina
gets sick I can get it seen three times
in one
day
baby you might be the funniest person on
the planet man call me trash you got me
mixed up with macdon yeah
[__] I say you're all class baby thank
you baby I'm J I'm trash and I'm sitting
there with two healthc care you don't
lost your damn mind and I got American
Express
card oh my head hurt I wasn't trash when
I was po cuz I used to steal good
stuff my nose is running my head hurts
oh okay thank youall so much ladies and
gentlemen the new show on BET Miss Pat
settles it you got to check it out it's
absolutely killing it yeah every
Wednesday night at 10 o'cl come on help
me break it is funny if you hey this was
funny podcast but y'all need to see me
rip people apart that walk in my
courtroom with that
crap ah kiy what do you got for him uh
guys we are uh we're all over the road
uh shows are selling out we're ring
shows there's probably I think 10 more
left for the for the rest of the year
get those tickets now uh thank you so
much Miss Pat this was unbelievable you
got Miss Pat settles it you got the Miss
Pat show about to do your fourth season
you're on tour you got the podcast you
got the special congratulations just go
to miss pacc comedy.com for all tour
dates cuz I'm out here she's a the the
maybe the hardest killer of of all time
it's crazy I honestly can't think
straight Miss Pat thank you so much we
love thank you for having me we love you
and we'll see you next week peace